it's so continuing our series on
omega-level mutant we pick up now with
strife now in the realm of Marvel Comics
for those of you guys who don't know
strife is what we call a heavy hitter he
is a big deal he is not afeared as
frequently as other big deals like
apocalypse or Magneto or somebody like
that but he is still a force to be
reckoned with the reason for this is
that strife and cable actually go hand
in hand there their origins their
stories are basically two halves of the
same coin two wide back for a second I
have a full explanation on cables origin
which you guys are welcome to check out
the link will be in the description but
the long and short of it was that cable
was born to Scott Summers and Madeline
prior and when he was born
apocalypse woke up realizing that cable
had immense power and this was important
because apocalypse his powers burned out
his bodies and so he had to basically
jump from human host to human host well
with cable with Nathan he wouldn't have
to do that Nathan was so powerful that
he would be able to withstand the powers
of apocalypse and so apocalypse
kidnapped cable took him to a ship and
infected him with a techno-organic virus
which is a virus that converts living
tissue to machinery and the reason why
apocalypse did this is because in his
mind if cable could withstand the
experience of being exposed to the
techno-organic virus and survive then
that would mean the cable is capable of
being apocalypses host you can basically
withstand anything and so the x-men
x-factor of these various groups got
together and they fought off apocalypse
and they managed to save Nathan but the
problem is that Nathan's exposure to the
techno-organic virus seemed irreversible
and so Nathan was sent to the future and
he was raised by Jean Grey and Scott
Summers and he was effectively taught
you know how to be a superhero well the
issue with this was that when Nathan was
first taken to the future because he was
infected with a techno-organic virus the
idea was that it may be incurable and
because it's incurable because there's
nothing they can do they decided to
clone cable well because this future was
ruled by apocalypse when cable arrived
in this timeline apocalypse saw him as
the child that he was unable to capture
in the past and so apocalypse sent his
forces to capture cable and
instead of actually capturing the real
cable apocalypses forces captured the
clone and so this clone is strife now
the reason why strife is a bad guy is
because under the control of apocalypse
stripes negativity his anger his rage
that was all encouraged it was all
driven to the surface as opposed to
being suppressed
in light of superhero tendencies and so
while cable grew up to be a super hero
under the leadership of Jean Grey and
Scott Summers strife grew up to be a
villain under the control of Apocalypse
Now while these two while both Kol and
strife never really knew the relation to
one another they never really knew their
origins this came to a head when the two
of them began fighting one another and
the reason for this was that apocalypse
was killed at some point in the future
apocalypse was defeated and officially
cast off he was no longer part of the of
the Marvel landscape and strife rose up
to take his place
and so cable formed a group called the
new Canaanites and strife formed a group
called the clan chosen and they
basically fought one another time and
time again this went on for decades now
eventually a peace treaty was signed
this issue came to an end strife
wouldn't let it go strife refused to
accept defeat and so what he did is he
basically used the time machine that
belonged to the to the clan chosen and
traveled back to the 20th century this
brings us to the first introduction of
strife in Marvel Comics now when he
first appeared he had a couple of cameos
here and there and he showed up maybe
some small story arcs but the first
Grand Poobah in your face here are the
things that strife can do storyline came
with executioner song an executioner
song was basically strife making his
move to eliminate cable he attacked
Charles Xavier
he attacked the x-men he attacked
virtually everybody but the big Q about
strife being as powerful as he is came
during the executioner song story when
he kidnapped Jean Grey and Scott Summers
and shut off their ability to use their
powers and this is a very big deal
because with Cyclops it's not that hard
his eyes are portals he can shoot lasers
out of him is a really cool concept with
Jean Grey she was a host for the Phoenix
force but even without the Phoenix force
she's still a wildly powerful telepath
and so this tells us just how powerful
strife is in relation to Jean Grey now
the reason why strife is so powerful is
because unlike cable strife was not
exposed to the techno-organic virus and
so where Cable has to use
is telepathy and telekinesis to keep the
virus from taking over his body
strife doesn't have two strikes powers
were just allowed to grow to therefore
wish and they were allowed to grow to
their to their full potential and so
strife basically begins a series of
campaigns now the problem with this is
that strife following the executioner
song had a lot of minor appearances we
showed up here and there and a couple
stories but Marlon never really did
anything with him and the reason for
this was because in the 1990s it was it
was high-octane fast page stories you
know in the 2000's Joe Quesada was
running the show and so he wanted
classic Marvel and that meant that
characters like strife had to take a
backseat
now all this changed after the house of
him and the house of him was a story
where the Scarlet Witch had worked
reality and changed the lives of
everybody well in the House of M was
corrected she set things back to normal
but split 98% of the mutant population
of their powers now while there were a
lot of things that were going on after
the House of M event the two things that
we really need to worry about it really
the only one thing we need to worry
about is what's called Messiah War and
this is what dealt with the
reintroduction of strife and to Marvel
Comics now he had been resurrected but
there was some continuity issues things
that didn't really make a whole lot of
sense and in order to keep this from
being too confusing I'm going to go
ahead and leave all that stuff out
but what ends up happening is that after
the events of house of M a girl named
Hope Summers is born and hope is the
first mutant born since the the
conclusion of house of M and so it's a
very big deal there's all kinds of
prophecies about her and different
things like that well a notable
character in this is Bishop and all we
had known about Bishop up to this point
was that he hail from a future that was
similar to Days of Future past but we
never found out what happened that
caused that future to take place and
what we learn is that in bishops
timeline Hope Summers killed a million
humans and so what Bishop intends to do
is kill Hope Summers now cable steps tin
and cable takes hope summers they start
jumping through the time stream and
Bishop follows them but because cable
and hope are sort of on their own all
these roads start intertwining and start
coming into the fray Cyclops sends the
uncanny x-force team of Wolverine and
warpath and so on and so forth sends all
them into the future chase after cable
and they keep both him and hope summers
protective but what happens is along the
line Bishop runs into strife in the
future now as far as I know we don't
know why strife is there he's just there
he's just a person in this
and so when is it happening is Bishop
help strife take over the world so that
strife will help Bishop with his own
goals but Bishop doesn't really say what
these are he just says he'll ask for
stripes help eventually and so what
happens is because cable and Hope
Summers are living in this time period
where strife rules the world eventually
strife becomes aware of the fact that
they're there and so strife sends out
his forces and he and cable begin to
battle one another let the same time
because Bishop and strife had attacked
apocalypse in his rejuvenation chamber
and tried to kill him it turned out
apocalypse didn't die and so at the end
of this great big story arc you
basically have cable and an Hope Summers
and uncanny x-force and apocalypse in
Archangel all fighting against strife
and Bishop and even Bishop turns on
strife and this is the real Q about how
powerful strife is strife takes all of
them on by himself every last one of
them takes every single person he takes
on uncanny x-force she takes on
apocalypse he takes on cable you takes
on hope well at least what little hope
can do be takes on apocalypse all of
them at the exact same time and this is
a testament to just how powerful strife
is now let's get into the nitty-gritty
of it let's get into the powers of
strife what all can he do well because
strife is an omega-level mutant
specifically in omega-level telepath and
telekinetic what this means is that
there's no limit to the things you can
do this is what differentiates an
omega-level mutant from a non
omega-level mutant an on Omega level
mutant like an alpha level mutant is
someone who has telepathy but they
basically just reached a plateau they've
reached a point where their powers just
can't go any higher they can't read any
more Minds than they already have they
can only read the minds of everybody in
the world like Charles Xavier but they
can't read the minds of like everybody
in the universe and so strife does not
have that problem there is no limit to
what strife can do and so he has all the
powers of your regular telepath but they
go beyond anything those telepaths can
do so he's much like Nate gray from the
Age of Apocalypse storyline which again
I have a video on him but you're welcome
to check out in the sense that strife
can basically create Holograms using his
mind and manipulating various molecules
around him he can control the minds of
others he can trap people in their own
lines he can read minds of multiple
people at same time you can control huge
groups of people at same time he can do
all kinds of cool stuff but the really
cool element of this is his telekinesis
because there's no limit to what it is
he's capable of again he's much like
Nate grey because everything in the
Marvel Universe consists of atoms which
make up molecules and so on and so forth
with telekinesis assuming that he was
able to achieve some measure of cosmic
awareness which is entirely possible
strife would be able to manipulate the
atoms of matter itself and effectively
control reality now this has never
happened in Marvel Comics and there's no
indication that it ever will
especially with all-new all-different
marvel kind of rebooting everything and
the fact that strife is nowhere to be
seen but the fact remains here that this
is entirely possible for his character
this is why he's such a powerful
individual because there's no limit to
what it is that he can do with regards
to the ability to control objects using
his mind and manipulate objects using
telekinesis with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end let me
know what you guys think and yeah I will
catch you guys on please